[Music]
uh i may have found the most beautiful
news article of the day oh thank god we
need some good news man we've been doing
too many negative news is it written in
calligraphy wow it should be cool that'd
be cool how good it is it should be
written in the candlelight sands
gothic sands uh the first ever scan of a
dying human brain reveals
that life may actually flash before your
eyes whoa whoa i heard about this what
do you mean like it plays uh what you
remember well what happened it's it's
it's sad but kind of cool but this um
they were studying this person's brain
reactions because this person was uh
experiencing some seizures so they put
them in a scan machine as they were
looking at the activity that person died
whoa
and that's never happened so it wasn't
like an intentional thing they were just
scanning not intentional at all so they
say they've never had a live scan of a
dying person do we know if they jinxed
it though were they like we hope he
doesn't die and they're like oh the
power of jinx yeah
jinx will get you so they were able to
see in those scans that um i mean of
course this is just like an inference
but like they were able to see that the
same activity in your brain happens as
when you're dreaming like
when you're bringing the lucid state
yeah yeah so it's very similar to that
but they can't really say 100 that oh
it's just like you know but for what
they've seen what they compared to it's
the closest i'm glad that they made
whoever made the human mind or brain or
experience is johnson johnson thank you
they devised a way to make it
comfortable
yeah
what which part death no like just just
just just going away it's it's a
comfortable ending you know yeah it's
supposed to feel like a warm blanket and
then you're like right and it smells
like we're tired then how come in the
movies they're like i'm cold it's so
cold
so we suppose we're not good actors
well actually what really happened yeah
just that moment in bart's brain where
he's like
it didn't work not good actors so are we
supposed to cut to like radical [ __ ]
tornado footage now and be like
it's like a warm blanket
the guy's hanging off the tree don't
worry don't just be like a warbling or
just shoot people in shock like going
into their last final shock
yeah that looks real warm it's a warm
boy
i guess that was a really warm blanket
is it is it like the brain in terms of
uh is it just like random like pew pew
pew pew or do you feel like it's like
when you like uh burn the lint off your
sock where it's like
oh
and everything from like every kind of
facet of your brain just kind of like
i like the how the second one looks
that'd be tight i feel like what it's
doing is uploading to the cloud
oh [ __ ] it's doing a quick little
pound and it goes in your photos app
creates like little memories of like of
your wife and then or like the the trip
you took last spring it's probably the
same thing do you think that when you're
dying it comes in a [ __ ] ken burn
slideshow they make slideshows all the
time do you think that when you're dying
if you if you're you're you're being
uploaded to the cloud but then like
you're like hey your cloud source is
full you can pay for the plan you can go
to [ __ ] help
what do you got you gotta pay for
justice credits you know like how many
good deeds do you have it depends if
when you were born if you were signed
into mediafire or mega upload
see that that's
what if it's like inception and you get
to relive your life again in your mind
so that one second is actually all the
years up to this point like last the
mohicans yeah yeah wait that happens and
less than the value yeah it doesn't get
hanged in the beginning and then like he
starts again he just remembers like his
whole [ __ ] thing and then the spoiler
alert it's a 1970s movie wait is this
the book or the movie
yeah i thought it was kevin costner i'm
thinking about some other movie though
what are you thinking of a freaking
looper i think it was avatar
nice thank you
dances with wolves i was taking dances
with wolves do you guys know anybody
that has had like a near-death
experience and they anecdotally say like
oh my life
actually yeah i have a friend from high
school who was like pronounced dead for
like i think like a minute something
seconds oh [ __ ] do i know him [ __ ] akira
sawada yeah oh i know him okay yeah yeah
i do know though
but can we talk about it for a second
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're dropping it as
usual let's go back to that luna baby
hey somebody in the room knows him me
all right cool and we never heard from
him again
no he but but last time i heard he went
to afghanistan yeah yeah yeah and then
he was a part of like a bomb diffusion
squad or something like that i think we
want to know about the death for a
minute let's get to something
interesting
the relevant fact where did he grow hey
where did he grow up in the sgv you
[ __ ] what's his favorite color
his favorite pastrami at the hat is the
spicy kind
no i mean i don't know a whole lot i
just he just wrote a long thing about it
on his facebook what was it during
afghanistan no it was very it was recent
it was like last year or two years ago
but his um
i don't know here's the thing here's the
caveat about it if you're a religious
person
and that happens to you
most likely you're going to come back
and say that you saw god jesus you went
to the light you heard the song of
solomon but he became atheists after no
no he i think he related most of his
experience like to you know god or you
know most of those bible stuff so no
life flashing before there was nothing
like you know cool sound i mean sorry
dude but like i think
there was nothing there was nothing like
supernatural you know it's not like he
saw this thing we just lost a subscriber
he didn't really see anything new he
just saw everything biblical oh okay
all i want to know is did joe know the
guy
[Laughter]
i do
i i will say that
i do feel like things move in really
really slow motion when you're in those
intense moments sometimes yeah right
like i remember being in a crazy car
accident uh in boynton park one time and
we got t-boned i was in the back seat
with no seat belt we got t-boned by like
a tacoma in the middle of the
intersection geez
and uh
for whatever reason i'm sure it happened
in half a second because that's how
[ __ ] fast that is
but being able to see the corner of the
car
and you see
yeah and then just seeing the glass even
from the mirror or the window just like
break and shatter and me falling
sideways before blacking out
for some reason i have such vivid
understanding of imagery of that and it
felt like it took like a minute for it
to happen
what kind of car was it we were
we were in like an old school celebrity
or something like that old school car
where'd you buy it from shut the [ __ ] up
is that cerritos auto square
with the keys and man ice this show
sometimes man
that's why we don't win any streamies
asking the questions people want to know
the answers did i have a roof rack or
not
that's what i want to know
[Music]
that's it dude i'm done
all right you say you remember that
moment right where were you guys going
you caught home yeah yeah
you're gonna
do that man where are you guys going huh
imagine you wake up from a car accident
the cop goes what kind of priors you
have
you're just like just bleeding and [ __ ]
[ __ ] kidding
yeah because it's irvine they don't like
you i said boy to park so you're in
there slow motion wise right all that
stuff but is there a moment afterwards
where you're like holy [ __ ] it was
blackness honestly slow motion
everything's crazy and stuff like that
there's blackness when you come too
you don't
well obviously i was still in a very
stressed situation so i wasn't thinking
about what i was thinking about i was
processing what was going on the driver
was passed the [ __ ] out and there's
smoke coming out of the vents and his
foot's still on the gas so we're like
slowly kind of doing doughnuts
and then my homie he's like kind of is
barely coming too also and so i hit him
i'm like put the [ __ ] car in park and
he like slams in the park right before
we almost hit a pole
so it was [ __ ] was your body like
achy was it like i just [ __ ] slammed
into some [ __ ] it was just adrenaline i
guess because like the second i like hit
the edge like knocked out for a second
but when i came back everything just
looked way different obviously it's just
the [ __ ] everywhere you can't process
like what was and what is you're just
like what the [ __ ] is this and then i
knew because we were still in motion the
car was like still in motion just like
with his heavy foot on it
i was just like oh man we need to stop
being in motion and by the time we got
out we like looked the other car and
everything that was going on um i just
saw my homies eyes were in the back of
his head and he was just like this just
out and he had blood all over his face
and [ __ ] like that and
i had to slap him to wake him up and
then the car door wouldn't open this up
so he had to crawl out the other side
but it's crazy lucky you no seat belt
stupid me but yes absolutely why don't
you have your seatbelt on because you
know when you're done you're sitting in
the back in the [ __ ] middle you know
when you're cool
because you know when you're the coolest
guy in school
you're just kind of like up on that
trying to have a conversation and be in
the know and stuff and then [ __ ]
t-bone comes you just you know when
you're cool just sag your seat belt a
little bit
he wears it around his butt
all the way down
your whole car you're just kind of
outside of it
was your friend okay he was okay yeah
everybody's okay oh that's not what my
question was sorry does did joe know
your friend
yeah do i know this person can he
corroborate this no no no no unimportant
to me
what's this in irvine we can move on
what's going on
[Laughter]
it does sound like i [ __ ] made up a
crazy-ass name
[Music]
you